fame fortune and success Hollywood's
hottest couple had it all but after
almost a decade together Angelina Jolie
and Brad Pitt were still missing one
thing a wedding ring but not anymore
Brad flashed his golden band during a
trip to Britain to promote his new movie
the pair said i do before friends and
family in a small chapel at their french
chateau the celebrity super couple got
engaged in 2012 but didn't want to tie
the knot until gay marriage became legal
in the US we actually really truly have
no date it's just um sound everywhere
something that makes sense to us and
would certainly yeah date wise yeah it's
absolutely rumored and I'm still hoping
you know we figured out our marriage
equality in the States it's for then the
wedding ends years of speculation about
when the celebrity super couple known as
Brangelina would officially tie the knot
the two never leave home without their
six kids and this weekend ceremony was
no exception Julie walked the aisle with
her two eldest sons while the others
through flower petals and served as ring
bearers this time around it looks like a
real Hollywood happy ending fit for the
big screen